sie tauschen ein hochrisiko gebiet gegen
eine idylle die volle stadt gegen die
ruhe fehlenden charme gegen den reiz der
natur
tausende pariser sind reif für die insel
reif für die idee schüler kommt ist
unternehmensberater hat sich für die
zeit der ausgangssperre in sein
ferienhaus zurückgezogen die kommenden
wochen wird er hier verbringen
hier habe ich ein büro in dem ich
arbeiten kann das macht für mich keinen
großen unterschied
combs arbeit und sein wohlstand erhalten
ihm einen gewissen freiraum die
staatlichen einschränkungen wegen des
virus offenbaren einmal mehr die
unterschiede zwischen arm und reich
dessen ist sich lacko bewusst
ich denke an die die in der region paris
geblieben sind und den kleinen wohnungen
leben zu mehreren auf 40 45
quadratmetern und die nicht die
möglichkeit haben einen so idyllischen
ort zu genießen in einer privilegierten
atmosphäre mit angenehmen
arbeitsbedingungen
das sind die menschen an die der
unternehmensberater auf seiner
idyllischen insel denkt home office ist
für die meisten ein ferner traum
sie arbeiten im supermarkt auf
baustellen oder als pflege kommt
rafik ben becker hält die französische
baguette tradition am laufen
14 stunden täglich seit corinna ist die
angst immer dabei ich stehe jeden tag
auf wir arbeiten ja gerne aber da ist
immer ein schlechtes gefühl im bauch
weil wir wissen dass wir engen kontakt
zu den kunden haben mit ihnen reden es
gibt keine große des abstands
markierungen am boden gen decke
schreiben über dem tresen grafik ben
becker schützt sich seine mitarbeiter
und kunden so gut es geht vor dem virus
wir können uns immer noch nicht an diese
situation gewöhnen
das herz unserer arbeit ist doch der
kontakt zum kunden es war und ist sehr
anstrengend die maske in der bäckerei zu
tragen und es gab immer wieder kunden
die keine maske auf hatten es nicht
ertrugen sie aufzusetzen sein genie hat
eine der höchsten infektionsraten in
ganz frankreich die sieben tage
incidents liegt bei 800 abstand halten
ist in den kleinen wohnungen und auch
auf dem markt unmöglich
wer hier lebt sieht was man so die krise
nicht in den griff bekommt die leute
tragen ihre masken nur über dem mund
nicht über der nase ist überall so das
ist das problem
sie sollten wieder alles zu machen wie
das andere länder machen wenn jeder den
ganzen tag raus kann wird es nicht
besser
die märkte der therese und ruhiger und
entspannter
in normalen zeiten ist die insel ein
urlaubsort für wohlhabende pariser in
der krise ein fluchtort das gibt der
familie die möglichkeit in freier
landschaft zu sein statt eingesperrt in
paris die kinder können im garten
man kann radfahren im umkreis von zehn
kilometern das ist angenehm
das funktioniert alles okay thomalla
combe kümmert sich um die häuser der
gäste der concierge ist einer von vielen
auf der insel die von der ausgangssperre
und den flüchtlingen die sie bringt
profitieren
die pariser machen einen großteil
unserer kunden aus sie sind ein
bedeutender teil frankreichs sie sind
zahlreich
sie wollen ihrem alltag entkommen und
die idee ist ein fabelhafter ort dafür
doch die idylle ist nicht ungetrübt denn
im gepäck manchen gastes aus dem hoch
incidents gebiet paris reiste in den
vergangenen monaten auch das virus an
und so ist das verhältnis von insulanern
und bewohnern ambivalent wir brauchen
sie aber die die auf die insel kommen
fühlen sich ganz wie im urlaub
sie tragen keine masken und nutzen kein
hand gehen sie weigern sich die zu
benutzen und masken zu tragen
machen sie sich keine sorgen sagt der
arzt sie sind in guten händen
ein corona patient im krankenhaus von st
antoni hat eine angstattacke auch bei
der gesundheitsversorgung gibt es in
frankreich zwei welten die region um st
antoni hat weniger ausstattung weniger
ärzte in der intensivstation ist das
limit schon überschritten
normalerweise haben wir 18 betten jetzt
sind es 26 und es werden noch mehr
werden
wir müssen viele patienten in andere
krankenhäuser fällig
lange trotz der emanuel macau den
forderungen der ärzte nach härteren
maßnahmen einen neuen landesweiten
strengen lockdown wollte er ein jahr vor
der wahl vermeiden
wir hatten recht am 29 januar keine
schließungen zu verhängen und wir lagen
richtig das öffentliche leben etwas zu
bremsen
im verlauf der epidemie ergreifen wir
nützliche maßnahmen wenn es an der zeit
ist
wenig später ist es an der zeit makro
korrigiert sich angesichts steigender
fallzahlen die bisherigen anstrengungen
reichten nicht aus während die epidemie
zur selben zeit voran preschen die
beschleunigung ist auch die neue
variante des virus zurückzuführen wir
verlieren die kontrolle wenn wir jetzt
nicht handeln
die nächtliche ausgangssperre und die
reisebeschränkungen gelten nun in ganz
frankreich aber den landesweiten
strengen lockdown verweigert makro
weiter stattdessen öffnen im ganzen land
in dieser woche große impfzentren wie
dieses im stadion von san do nicht zum
ersten mal in der krise sehen auch die
menschen hier
einen ausweg die einzige lösung um aus
dieser epidemie rauszukommen ist das
impfen
das massive impfen wenn die ausgangs
beschränkungen aufgehoben sind ledig
teils teils in paris das virus hat das
land gespalten in die die auf ihre insel
fliegen können und die die das nicht
können jetzt 1 sie die hoffnung die
korona krise zu überwinden